[Music]
[Applause]
oh no we're lost
what you guys gonna get the countdown
we're on the internet we're just live
streaming where am I get into it welcome
back to who am I at yes and you know
improv welcome back to the break room
you guys our daily show that keeps you
updated on all the nerdy news that you
guys need to know coming up uh who's
knocking at that door come and knock on
our door
this is
a sitcom this is a we are a sitcom you
guys a queen a naughty space Oh no HBO
gets a new Max price get ready to pay up
we go across we got some new across the
spiderverse logo versus so spider logo
versus and much much more but first the
man jabbing his hands really
aggressively here we go
yeah yeah
um Jessica Clemens here and then we got
Tommy bechtold good evening let's get to
the show oh
so abrupt you ready get to the headline
I've got a very busy night watching
basketball and crying out of me how much
money you put down
it's 20 spot I told you to stop betting
the house hey let him give him I bet on
myself okay I'm gambled on myself and
that's why I'm always broke God damn a
new poster for the M Night shyamalan's
knock at the cabin just came out the new
movie uh focuses on oh look at it it
kind of does resemble cabin in the woods
but we're not going to address that uh I
love that the fingers are separated by
the people and Dave Batista's the thumb
yeah uh this new movie focuses on the
family vacation that is held hostage by
four strangers who demand a sacrifice in
order to prevent the apocalypse this
film stars Dave Batista and Rupert Grant
along with Jonathan Groff and releases
February 3rd I can't wait to see this
movie and see how David Batista
surprises us with a uh Drex Cameo yeah
just like in the middle of it he takes
his shirt off and just his body he's
only got that paint you don't see it as
dry because all the paint but like when
he plays different roles and then it
always does a close-up always does a
close-up of his knuckles and you see the
Wu-Tang symbol and I'm like oh you're
gonna kill these people for the
apocalypse but you also listen to
Wu-Tang oh yeah right while doing that's
where he got the idea it was always
talking about the apocalypse
Jesus Christ Noah Holly is uh upcoming
Alien series is to begin production this
year the FX chairman John landgraf I
probably pronounce that wrong you're a
chairman I don't really care if I did uh
so that filming will begin once Holly is
finished with season five of Fargo
Hollis has said that the series will be
set on Earth of the future alien is a
fascinating story because it is not just
a monster movie it's about how we're
trapped between the primordial past and
the artificial intelligence of our
future where both are trying to kill us
if this production schedule holds true
we can expect the series to Premiere
sometime in 2024.
[Music]
[Laughter]
alien also teaches us uh I always listen
to the woman that's something they
always oh yeah it wasn't up until the
80s words but alien came out prior to
that women were better like encouraged
from being listened to except for when
they told us their secret sweet sweet
recipes oh I thought you were gonna say
something else at the end of a secret
sweet sweet sweet sweet
language
and I have to spend like four days with
you guys this weekend yes that's right
we're all going to Manitoba oh yeah
Canada's not gonna know what hit it eh I
thought we were going to Toronto for the
first time since launching HBO Max is
raising their subscription price for the
first time
I like their business model of getting
rid of the content people like and
canceling things that's true and you're
gonna pay us a dollar that is true this
is officially a hostage situation it's
very 21st century capitalist and I'm
here for it you want us to take you want
to keep Curb Your Enthusiasm on this
channel it's gonna be 16.99 next year
that is interesting they did like I mean
I understand that maybe it's also
because they're merging with I'll finish
this and we'll get into it so February
11th the US subscribers will have a
price increase from 14.99 to 15.99 the
company says the increase will allow us
to continue to invest in providing even
more culture defining programming and
improving our customer experience for
all users they put culture defining in
there so it would sway you guys
recognize that they are just making
these keywords these are hot words to
say to you so you're like okay as long
as it's culture defined and programming
it's not they're going to bring Shark
Week on that's right it's going to be
more bad reality TV and also like what
they whispered after that was like
unless it's an animated show in which we
will devastate the creators and creative
teams behind it by canceling it and
taking it off the internet for or taking
enough streaming forever you'll never be
able to find these animated shows
because screw animation we don't respect
it yeah just like that yeah that's
exactly what they said and I stand by
anything Tommy I said yeah I mean
anything and everything as Jason Momoa
swan song from Aquaman probably uh
they're gonna do a crossover with
Aquaman and shark week so it's going to
be a whole today I will punch the first
shark in the nose I see if that happens
yeah he's shark repellent like that no
I'm gonna punch him straight in the nose
Matt Reeves while discussing the 15th
anniversary of Cloverfield you guys I'm
gonna keep reading this I'm gonna keep
reading this I just have to say I told
dashel this my voice it sounds like it's
gone I guess I choked in my sleep last
night uh my roommate was like you were
hacking and I was like since when and I
guess I was asleep are you gonna be too
sick to go on our trip to Toronto I'm
not sick my voice has just gone from
joking last night
and then you hit under my bed when my
roommate
I'm a lamb they said nothing weird about
that lamp over there Jessica has an
overhead ceiling why is it so sweaty now
that lamp is sweating it's heaving for
breath
you know you're out of shape when you
start choking from children
some vigorous activities
[Laughter]
come on Matt Reeves while discussing the
15th anniversary of Cloverfield revealed
he will be sitting down with James Gunn
some Peter Sanford later this month to
discuss the future of the Batman y'all
Reef said he's already had some talks
with gun and saffron and they will have
a sit down where we talk about
everything that's going on in the ark so
where these two things are and I'm
excited to hear about what they're doing
sounds like this man wants to keep his
thing to himself Reeves has already
announced plans for both a Batman sequel
and an HBO spin-off focusing on what
really this the star of the Batman for
me which was the penguin yeah absolutely
he stole the he stole the show for me
Colin Farrell did a fantastic job I'm
very excited for that series I love the
tape he made uh with that girl Nicole
Lorraine as well that movie that short
film he made yeah Google it all right
okay wait is it appropriate no oh fun
good thing we're on the internet new
photos from there across the spider
versus Twitter reveals nine spider
people logos that would be important in
the upcoming film and we know these are
important because we got miles morality
okay we're gonna go top left over we
have Miles Morales we have Gwen Stacy we
have wait which one's good there's Gwen
there you go thank you thank you Joshua
Gwen Stacy uh Spider-Man 2099 Miguel
O'Hara we have Spider Woman Jessica Drew
Spider-Man India private chair provoker
sorry I probably butchered that spider
Punk Colby Hobart Scarlett uh Scarlet
Spider Ben Reilly cyborg Spider Woman
which is very very cyborg Spider Woman
is very new we'll get into it and Spider
by uh spider bite Margo
[Music]
spider but cyborg spiderwe
and no Peter oh no Peter B Parker that
is a big well okay so we know that uh
Peter B Parker's having a baby May May
Day and
um thank you and so that I think that
maybe that's probably why he's not gonna
be doing too much spidermanning because
he's gonna be like I'm teaching my
daughter because she has Spider-Man
Powers they said that she will have the
same Spider-Man powers and then also uh
if we're talking about cyborg like the
electronic kind of Spider-Man legged uh
Renaissance Spider-Man that's Aunt May
is insane if she's the one that's cyborg
oh all right she's really cool she's
very sick awesome real quick you are
kind of wearing Spider Woman colors
right now are actually Gryffindor but
thank you for trying
out of here right now he would look like
Spider Woman voiced by Issa ring I'll go
with that one because I'm a Slytherin
and I do not I am also a Slytherin
you're a Hufflepuff you're a freaking
Hufflepuff will you read this one yeah
sure kiwan from Encino Man told happy
sad confused podcast that Kevin feige
personally reached out to him to join
the cast of Loki season two all right
pick that name up off the floor
after the success of everything
everywhere all at once Quan said the
first phone call I got was from Kevin
feige who graciously asked me if I
wanted to join the MCU and I called
Jonathan in the gang and I said you know
what nobody wants to hire me except
Steven Spielberg George Lucas the
Daniels and Kevin feike feige Kevin
feige Kevin feige I'm having a stroky
Kevin
I smell pennies it's been incredible
2022 is the year I will always remember
because it is one of the happiest years
of my life as children immediately went
hey what are we talking about okay guys
the details of his roles have not yet
been confirmed by Marvel but it's
thought that he'll be working for the
TVA seems kind of like a racist
assumption administrative no he might
is working like in the field you think
he's a field agent
accounting
well I mean if he's just as prominent as
Eugene Cordero is then he gets his own
like he's gonna become the new
um Madison from she-hole
um I just want everything best for him I
cried three times this morning at
different Tick Tock videos and one of
them was his acceptance speech at the
Golden Globes and how he was like as a
child I was lucky and now and then after
that went out I was like I'm not lucky
anymore and now look at him look at him
he's doing great I would love to know I
would be fascinated to listen to and I
wonder if this podcast exists call in if
it does like what he did from like 1989
to to 2015. well I guess he didn't see
no man right but that was like 89. like
right like I mean I'm sure if I I'm sure
this can all be
that was my thought is like you know
obviously famously the the guy who
played Chunk is an entertainment
attorney and you know oh some of the
other actors have got that in those in
those movies a lot of child actors stay
in the industry in different ways the
ones that have healthy happy endings the
ones that have sad tragic endings are
generally uh as we all know as people in
Hollywood if it's not acting it's
nothing that's right it's nothing if
you're not on camera you're a shamra
anyway Jessica we have some people to
think we got some people to think oh
wait first starting with John Adam
coming on camera
for people we want to think we're all
trying to save money in 2023 upside is
an incredible app for everyone who buys
gas groceries or dines out and I do all
three every single day yes do i as you
you no
no oh no okay what what upside you can
get cash I'm not allowed in gas stations
because of the Patriot Act and I can't
buy groceries because oh I'm allergic to
produce and gas and dining out are two
things that I've had a lot of trouble
with in the past
not for Tommy but for us with upside you
can get cash back on purchases you make
every day it's basically cash back just
for you upside even offsets inflated
prices by giving you cash back on
purchases it's also super easy to use to
get started download the free upside app
use our promo code break room and get an
extra 25 cents back for every gallon on
your first tank of gas and in this in
this economy that's needed a whole
quarter coming
I wish it was real quarters they sent
you a bag of quarters in the mail then
I'd do it what so you can beat someone
up with it so I can swing my signature
weapon a loose graphic tee full of
quarters raining out of it
oh God don't be Tommy what is that the
who
inside then pay as usual with credit or
debit card follow the steps in the app
and get paid you can earn three times
more cash back with upside than with
most Credit Card Rewards or loyalty
programs plus upside doesn't sell your
personal information to third parties
which is very important because we don't
want them doing that upside users are
earning hundreds of dollars a year
that's probably why they have a 4.8 star
rating on the app store they're
basically out of five yes it was one
person that got mad download the free
upside app and use promo code break room
that's promo code break room to get
extra 25 cents back for every gallon on
your first tank of gas and baby get that
gas
you know what we also want to let you
know about hello fresh eating well is at
the top of everyone's mind this month
and should be for all months because if
you eat well you feel well and if you
feel well you treat other people well
unless you know you're like an A-list
actor who abuses their assistant it's
comforting to know you always get top
quality with hello fresh hello fresh mix
dinner time easy peasy Fast and Fresh
and Furious recipes coming your way
hellofresh also has a line of delicious
filling meals that are ready in less
than 15 minutes enjoy taste and quality
Done Quick with recipes like Sesame beef
tacos fries spiced pork meatballs and my
personal favorite winner winner orzo
chicken dinner meal
we've said a lot of SOB stories this
week about my hellofresh experience but
I want to talk about some positivity
last night I cooked up a hellofresh meal
and I set a table for two
and no no one ate that second plate and
I spent most of the dinner singing out
when will my love come eat with me I'm
sick of sitting here silently
chicken dinners are always best enjoyed
by two
hello Fresh Out always love you
[Applause]
and then a little mouse
took my napkin off my chest and burrowed
into it and I had to go to the doctor
see if I had an infection hello fresh is
America's number one meal kit and you
should try it for yourself go to
hellofresh.com breakroom 22 use the code
breakroom 22 for 22 free meals plus free
shipping that is an Emmett Smith jersey
number of free meals that's
hellofresh.com break room 22 and use
code break room 22 remember you use the
code you get the meals you help us it's
the circle of life guys you do that
and we'll appreciate it we want to thank
some super Chatters Daniel Garcia I said
am I the only one thinking that Kang
Dynasty will be a movie showing a lot of
Kang variants in their rise to power
rabbitut he who remains
Etc yes you are
um I think that Kang's done personally I
think that's a great idea but I think
that's what we're kind of gonna get with
Secret Wars I really want Kang's Dynasty
to be king the Conqueror I want us to
see his Evolution through this entire
face to Kang Dynasty how he's gonna
conquer a bunch of different times he's
going to enter the Multiverse and be
able to conquer everything and he is
going to be King's Dynasty but that's
personally how I feel Daniel Garcia
which is my high school boyfriend's name
uh is this you is this you is this send
us in another 4.99 Super Chat to let us
know
he's like yes yes it is can I have my
five dollars back now but that kind of
leads us into our discussion right
Jessica I mean that we we want to talk
more about
things so our discussion today is more
about Kang and a lot of his motivations
because usually lately Marlo Marlo Marlo
my favorite water character that's my
favorite fish Marvel villains had more
sorry uh we just wanted to talk about
Kang and his uh reasoning for everything
that he's doing because lately Marvel
villains had had uh had had more depth
than I just want to destroy everything
right they have actual reasoning to do
things uh killmonger's my favorite one
uh Thanos was a great justifier Gore the
god butcher daughter died in his arms
from starvation and dehydration at the
hands of gods who were in their little
Garden of Eden slurping grapes and
kissing Apes
they were doing that in that order I
think they were but I but that was a
great example too is Gore the god
butcher just uh I prayed this guy every
day and he never came Whiplash you know
they took his board
I wanted my bullied back Iron Man Too oh
my God bring me back my boy I was
thinking of the the skating movie I was
like what are you talking about isn't
that a German movie oh my okay either
way either way
pennies again either way you are right I
was thinking of whip it absolutely
um if it's not a superhero movie I don't
know it but our heroes and our villains
have become more in depth but just the
villains itself has such good
justifications they need it now they
can't just be evil I I need reason I
need y I need I mean why why why so I'm
asking all of us today to have our
theories of what Kang's actual
motivation is more than just he's evil
his name is King the Conqueror he just
wants to conquer no I want to know why
he wants to conquer and I want to know
what started all of this because he
started as a normal man at one point or
maybe he didn't but either way he has to
be justified uh Daniel Garcia you are a
peach of a man for actually sending
another Super Chat it is not your high
school boyfriend but he says he's a huge
fan he watches us all the time loves the
theories and he would like to see uh
would love to be able to get in touch to
get in touch well you are in touch with
us and we're in touch with you you've
touched our hearts thank you but if you
want to give us a punk call give us a
phone call 1-800-22 John will you send
Daniel my address uh all right I have my
theory yeah I'll go first I don't need
you I can do this I mean I need you Mr
multitasker I know you need me listen
I think the king that's in the quantum
realm is actually a king that has met
some people in the TVA before I think
you know when the comics Ramona
rensslayer is a love interest for King
I think Kang in the quantum realm and
ravona Rensselaer had a relationship
maybe she didn't know he was a king
maybe he was just posing maybe he was
posing as a high school principal at her
thing and they were in love and then he
who remains
peered in upon that King because that he
remains as like the intellectual
scholarly Kang kind of seems as though
he has the most uh Kang visibility and
and knowledge of other kings and he fell
in love with in front of rensslayer and
his solution was to banish that King
King the Conquering King to the quantum
realm so that he could be with ravona
rensslayer and in doing that he had to
erase her memories and uh you know or
wait the the one in the quantum realm
yes no the no he who remains
Jessica your question has now confused
everyone
let me draw this out
even though they look exactly the same
he had to wipe her memory well no he had
to uh he had to get her into the TVA
because she's pruned yes and put in the
TVA and put to work so he did that so
they could have a fresh start so this is
he who remains
this is Kang the Conqueror King the
Conqueror was with Ramona rensslayer
okay
this guy saw Roberta rensslayer so he
took him threw him into the quantum
realm he ran a post route okay
can I Circle something can I ask you a
question you may not your last question
derailed to my entire Theory no you can
ask a question great now this cat's on
fine now the cat's on the floor my jeans
are too tight to bend why are you taking
it out of me zoom in on me zooming on me
um so are you saying that this the
um this not uh King the Conqueror but uh
our King he who remains from Loki season
one Jessica so yes do not raise your
voice at me I'm not he who remains
uh-huh and saw these two together and
literally jumped into that at that time
yes and said this woman is beautiful I
love her what is my how what can I do
take her prisoner classic Beauty and the
Beast move that's okay but he had to get
rid of the other Kang I'll a Hugh
Jackman in the prestige killing all his
clones so he sent him to the quantum
realm now
we think what have I done uh we think
that our uh that Kang from Ant-Man
quantumania
cue the Zach Galifianakis looking at
numbers gift from The Hangover because
you have derailed me this is your fault
no I'm just kidding I I've drowned
myself he's gonna Escape once he escapes
he's going to seek out he who remains
where is he who remains he's dead in a
chair Sylvie stabbing oh yeah but he's
gonna go to that realm where all the
pruned people go well guess who's in
that realm lots of evil timeline
variants of of of uh of of powerful
people stop talking to me watch
timeline people uh like like you know
there could be like an evil Thanos an
evil version of Loki or or a truly evil
chaotic evil version of Loki maybe other
villains we've seen maybe new villains I
believe that the r King the Conqueror
from quantumania is going to create a
high Council like there was the you know
the animatronic High Council he's going
to create a true High Council a council
of Kings or Kang Associates with people
he finds in the he who remains world
where all the pruned people went so I I
mean I think we could see like a
de-powered kind of nerfed Thanos without
the gauntlet sitting on that council
with like a president Loki or something
like that and then maybe like
I'm trying to think of like a good super
villain that we haven't seen yet that
you know maybe
what's that
Everett K Ross is Dr Doom so he will not
be doing that but you know maybe uh
maybe like a uh Red Skull or something
like that or morph what love to see more
morph is a good guy morph was killed in
the line of duty in X-Men the Animated
Series morph
needs to come back into the MCU as a
hero yeah so that's my theory is that
we're going to get King the Conqueror
back he's going to try and get revenge
on he who remains but in doing so we'll
realize he who remains is dead but in
that world there are pruned variants of
evil people that he can recruit bring
into the TVA world put them in the High
Council thus creating a council of kings
that is truly evil and messing with the
time I love that do you think the
post-credit for this movie then would be
like him at
into you I think the post-credit could
be them all like marching into the TVA
oh oh you're like management has changed
or shift change
like the whistle that blows in a factory
then they all punch in yeah I love that
and right on the board always be closing
that's right first set is the set first
prize is is set as a brand new Buick
Skylark second prize is a set of steak
knives their prizes you fired
oh man I hope I don't get third
how do you feel
I thank you for asking no you're such a
treasure I know don't ever change yeah
[Music]
listen I will pleasure myself to y'all's
quarrels at another time I know it's
Thursday hey yo so what I think is going
on with Kang the Conqueror and the
upcoming Ant-Man and Corner Mania moving
forward in the MCU I think Kang is in
the quantum realm okay because he's on
the run from the other kings yeah I
think the king we follow in this movie
film take that Scorsese in this film uh
is trying to be the one and only case
yeah yes uh Allah the Jet Li character
in that movie the one yes it was a
Multiverse movie from back in the day
yes I like that movie Jet Li versus Jet
Li was the poster that's great yes so I
think our King that we're following uh
wants to be the one and only Kang I
think he's on the run from other kings
because he's the most mischievous or
whatever he wants to be the only one so
he can effectively hide in the quantum
realm because it's kind of Off the Grid
off the radar of the multiverses and
also time works differently there as we
saw from Scott Lang being stuck down
there for five years missing everything
like five hours
um um the original wasp Jenna Van Dyne
being on there for 30 years missing a
whole bunch of stuff I think he can
effectively hide down there I don't know
why I'm holding this up I haven't
written you don't need to write anything
uh I guess I'll save that for later so
what his plan is is to since Scott Lang
has been stuck down there along with his
family is to get control or get Scott
Lang's help with his time Travel Time
Heist technology so that he can really
like instead of just hiding and staying
low from the other kings he can
effectively move through time in
different dimensions with his technology
and Scott Lang's Time Heist technology
to take out all the different Kings and
just be the one and only Kang the only
King the Conqueror oh my God okay
okay yeah no what does it take to be
number one two is not the winner and
three nobody remembers yeah if you're
not first you're last that's right yeah
I like I like the idea of Kang okay so
and we talked about this yesterday
briefly
um that the Silver Surfer people have
been known to hide in the quantum realm
in the comic books or the microverse and
the Silver Surfer was one that hid in
there because he didn't want to fight
with the Fantastic Four he didn't want
that stuff no I like uh well he didn't
want to I think they were ultimately
trying to fight Galactus and he was like
no I'm just like handy he's like I
finally got away oh quick footnote so
like that Silver Surf for example and
more MCU example uh the way Sylvie was
hiding in uh that area of chaos to hide
from being pruned that's true yeah and
all the difference yes 100
I like the way I like the idea of Kang
being able to get in but not getting
able to get out it's like a cat or a cat
it's like a rat and a rat trap it's like
oh God I got in here the crabs crabs and
the octopuses go in and eat the crabs
and then they're smart enough to get out
sometimes and sometimes they're not so
that octopuses Scott is the pims and
Langs yeah okay I'm feeding into it now
uh what would that post-credit scene
look like then that post crazy
whoa hey
hey no more bourbon during the break
room Thirsty Thursdays are here to stay
[Music]
Eric gives a thirsty assassinated by the
way I'm gonna remind your projects he's
a fabulous actor Jessica thank you I
think Jessica's got an audition a couple
of months ago and she blew my socks off
okay then we taped the audition
God go ahead and tell me what your post
credits you telling me you blew his
socks off better than me how dare you
what is going on this is the Thursday we
need Zach or Brandon back yeah I don't
have thicker lips for no reason anyway
back to what we were talking about I'm
blushing the post credit scene of
quantumania uh will feature the king
we've watched the whole movie standing
on the ruins of the Illuminati Citadel
uh he has gone to the E38 Universe to go
[ __ ] [ __ ] up over there and use their
technology to to continue hunting all
the other kings you think he's gonna get
out he's going to jump to a3a and just
start messing with people to what part
of a3a you said sorry the a38 right
before Doctor Strange
I like the idea of a post credit scene
wrapping up a movie that already
happened like being like did you guys
miss this little bit so I'm into this
I'm into it good job
um mine
what happened are you good I'll just
never not read GSU Eagle 117's name that
they changed oh we'll answer the super
chats after I pitch my eyes
um so my idea for what Kang's
motivations are kind of aligned with
yours I think that he was banished
thereby he who remains because he said
at the end he was like if you think I'm
bad once you see my evil variants and I
think those are one of the variants that
he was like I met him he is chaotic he
is straight chaos and sweetie and Kevin
chaotic
yes 100 and so I think he genuinely was
like I have to banish him to somewhere
that's not where everyone else was
pruned because he can get out of that I
need to get him in the place that he
can't get out and I think they put him
in the quantum realm and he now can't
get out but they didn't he met Janet
there and figured out Janet the
scientist and either Bill Murray have
come with an invention that could
seemingly get him out but she already
left and now that she sucked back in
he's like you can finish what you
started and I think a lot of his
motivation is like I need to get out of
here not only to destroy he who remains
but eventually conquer worlds I think he
was already conquering out of just
wanting to be like Loki feared than love
and he loved taking over every kind of
Dimension and Multiverse so I think he
just wants to get out and first and
foremost hit up the TVA just like you
said
um I think for post credit scene though
I kind of wanted to be mysterious I want
them they're going to get out of the
quantum realm but I eventually want it
to just be Modoc getting out and and
he's very confused at where he's at but
he walks up or walks up flies up
whatever floats hovers Waddles to uh
grayburn college and this is the
introduction to him meeting the leader
in armor Wars I like
I think it's uh inevitably I want Modoc
to meet up the leader immediately so
they can start their Shenanigans or him
figuring out what the Intelligentsia was
in She-Hulk and I mean like I can do a
better job yeah and then creating them
what about a reboot to aim too perhaps
yeah perhaps aim could be the [ __ ] the
Shadow or the shell company behind Modoc
and the leaders uh Shenanigans
absolutely they could make aim seem like
it's a leader leader as a side to that
but correct for that uh we do gotta get
into aim in uh this week's Rogue theory
that comes out on Saturday
when Rogue with it and it was really
good introduction to aim oh Maddie I
love Maddie uh yeah check that out for
the fact of the incredible panelists on
that we've got Jessica Matt did Brandon
do it too yeah me and Matt Brandon and I
am
staple all right well thanks for super
Chatters uh everything these are sploots
if dream games are other versions of
yourself does that mean each Kang is
basically spying on each other that
might be something that he who remains
utilized the thing is I I 100 agree with
that I 100 agree with that and I just
think that there's a there's a wall that
you gotta hit with Kings eventually and
this is out of me being a person that
needs justifications for everything
Marvel does you have to hit a wall and
not every King has the same ability but
I think uh he who remains had that
ability to just like dream and see
everybody and make note of it kind of
what America Shabbos was doing because
that's what American job this was
basically doing she's like I don't have
dreams that's why I know there's not
another man another guy all right okay
that's also a very angsty thing for a
teenager but it's true oh it's not a
face she doesn't dream because there's
no other version of her I don't like
music all right anyway I listen to NPR I
only listen to podcasts about True Crime
now uh Danny Garcia once again I like
your theory I think Kang might have
traveled back in time maybe with a
partner he screwed over or the other way
around or possibly even a lot cover like
there's maybe rentslayer is a lover who
traveled back in time with it maybe they
are star-crossed lovers you know what I
okay I agree with you and I agree with
Daniel Garcia I think uh while I know
the MCU has a lot of love a lot of
lovey-dovey things going on but I love
the idea that it's okay we got the pims
and we got the Langs and if something
happens to one of the two they're gonna
be incomplete so it's like they need to
always be there it's love and family and
then Kang's like yeah I see you guys
with your love and your family but my
love and family is not in this freaking
realm is it a different place that's
what I'm gonna freak out I'm gonna freak
out speaking the freak out it's time for
mandatory fun no I'm not ready to Frick
fun and it's Thursday so you know we
play the graphic way too much
yes mandatory fun where I get my two
best friends in the whole world oh my
gosh join me in some uh non-optional fun
now I'm gonna go quickly get the dry
erasers because we've all doodled on our
dry eraser boards and Tommy does say
like my best friends but genuinely he
does hang out with me Eric a lot that is
true this might be the only time I mean
it now there's a movie coming out this
year that is absolutely gonna change the
way we think about Cinema for years to
come huh
that's fine your watch is so chatty and
it's on airplane mode and do not disturb
which is weird I think it's because my
fat hands just keep oh my God mine
clicks the thing too yes for some reason
when I check my health it's just a
tombstone all right now
there's a movie coming out this year
that is going to change the way we think
about Cinema for years to come I'm
talking of course about playing
what was it wait
perhaps the most genius title ever you
know exactly what the movie's about and
that's a play
stop saying it like that it got me
thinking about how we could rename MCU
movies with just one word so we're gonna
play a little game right now where I'm
gonna rename a famous MCU movie that's
fine that's not spoiler and uh you guys
are gonna guess what movie it is but uh
its new title and the winner uh will get
to rename one of us our Twitter handle
with just one name for 24 hours
well he's the one that gave the name
Ebenezer's Blues so if it's me it'll be
a cute one all right so the first one is
nepotism what MCU movie and there are
several
there's nepotism and I'm sorry because
this is there's not a lot of them you do
have to get the exact movie it can't be
the franchise oh yeah we're guessing the
movie not the person oh okay
this is a MCU movie nepotism
all right I think I got it all right and
three
two
one show them
you said Iron Man and you said Thor one
the answer is Iron Man what Stark
industry started by Howard Stark the
only reason we have an Iron Man as we
talked about on this show was thanks to
nepotism which doesn't mean the person
is untalented it just means they have an
inherent Advantage based on birth and
location
and also in Thor one wasn't he banished
yes so is it nepotism if you're banished
okay well dude I don't really need I
don't need you to pick a part of losing
answer that's just I mean that's that's
me roasting that's like kicking one of
the dead horses in my horse graveyard
bone horse is in the chat next one glove
glove oh no glove no love I know what
this is yeah it's about our trip this
weekend hey hey yo Toronto's not gonna
know what hit it yeah Manitoba more like
man I told you
and then three
two
one show me Avengers Infinity War
Eric
Avengers seven one Avengers one the
answer is Avengers Infinity War which of
course is about the gauntlet and getting
all the stones so it's two nothing now
all right I mean you can come back
mathematically how many rooms are we
doing they're six okay
that's right all right number three
amnesia
Amnesia give me one second
so you lost your memory right yeah
that's what I was trying to think of
what it meant amnesia
and this is not only movies right this
is only movies oh [ __ ] okay
the MCU movie I did not specify that I
did only do movies so I forgot about the
TV shows
and seven
six
five
four I looked at yours and you're right
two one and go I did Avengers Age of
Ultron okay Captain America no the
answer neither of you correct the answer
is Spider-Man no way home oh that makes
way more sense why did you say Captain
America too my Soldier yeah Winter
Soldier right yeah I uh said this for
vision did you delete one of mine
so there was only five
I know but I thought it was six that I
liked it
did you dare edit me show your face no
censorship at the house so it's two to
one or two to zero so Eric You Gotta
Give these last two right just a tie all
right cousins
they're cousins
that's a big clue
even though that's not even the right
word yeah
in their colors
look at me a high five I always thought
it was always give me a hug but but it's
still a high five that is a wider lyric
yeah well you know yes from the white
perspective from the white gays uh all
right uh white gays gays
I was about to call the Glad on you that
was about to put a phone call real fast
camera four yeah
you said it why are you coming as you
said it
canceled yeah where's the cancel sticker
all right three two one go
it is of course black panther you put an
S so oh no there's a point yeah sorry
yeah
whoever deleted
you know it's already hard for me
hey yo
all right uh that's what she said Mommy
the last one is Mommy
Mom oh I should write this out before
you I need the fall yeah unless Eric
writes it then in which case I know I
I'm aware of the rules
[Music]
this ain't Three's Company anymore
two one reveal mom yes it is Doctor
Strange Multiverse events I had to write
it out
Jessica you are the winner and therefore
you get to change my Twitter handle for
24 hours to a one word thing yeah you
get one word
um booty sauce that's two words
[Laughter]
nope that's quite the double word do you
remember when she was like I'll make it
nice right well it's because you came
for me with my black panther no you said
black panther I didn't mean really quick
I don't care what you meant the
Integrity of the game is everything to
me same with your name this is America's
classic game MCU movies by one word well
booty juices one that's also another
word
Tropic Thunder Tropic Thunder is one
word
um uh your stage name no you have to say
it on here so people don't think I just
went crazy you're right you're right
declared we only got 11 minutes left so
you got time this is called vamping
let's talk about life guys tomorrow
night Amazon Hunter season two on Prime
comes out I'm on episode seven all
episodes drop if you want to skip
straight to mine to be really disturbed
by your performance I play a horrible
person uh who does horrible things and
just remember it's acting guys it's
acting okay I
mean I did improvise most of the lines
John what are some of the names that are
coming through
[Laughter]
is that like a sauce I want
oh
sure a pootie pootie like pootie I like
your booty what'd you do Pootie Tang no
that's two words oh my god well you know
what maybe we're gonna use a super chats
for an in-house tutor so we can explain
how about Jeff how about putty no I just
spit on me
not here I'm a grinch
um no I like pootie it is well guys
that's all the time we have today uh
I've been pootie we want to thank Eric
and Jessica for joining us in another
fabulous episode of the break room join
us here tomorrow same Back Time same bat
Channel be sure to like And subscribe
and watch my modot's video out on the
channel now and watch Whitney's Cassie
Lang video right now let's learn a
little more about Cassie who is she
what's her deal what do you tell you
Whitney will tell you and uh Josh you
got any videos coming out nope
oh inside Marvel dropped today this
morning where we me and Mt go really in
depth with the trailer and just talk
about whether or not you know Ant-Man is
gonna be a good guy we've got all sorts
of Ant-Man content content
whoa guys should I work in advertising
we've got all your Quantum content here
on uh new rockstars everybody's got to
vent out don't forget ant-man's uh mt's
Ant-Man trailer breakdown is out now
check it out guys what a great time
we've all had today we've learned so
much about each other so much has been
revealed I can't wait to see what
tomorrow brings I love you all very much
sincerely yours
[Music]
it's true
[Music]